Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, breast cancer like any cancer diagnosis can be very scary
and it can be worrisome.
And when you hear that C word, it brings out a lot of anxiety, it stimulates your sympathetic
nervous system to go into fight or flight.
When you hear the diagnosis, it can be very scary.
Be careful, that's my first piece of advice, to slow down and to consider your options.
Standards of care are going to give you very specific options, chemotherapy, radiation,
surgery, and it's easy to get hurted down a pathway that you might later regret.
Not that these therapies, standards of care aren't right for everybody.
But you have to realize that alternative care is not exclusive from them.
We have hundreds of patients that are doing some standards of care of some level, but
have added on alternative care to increase the benefit of those other standards of care
like chemo or radiation and to improve their outcome.
When you change your diet and you do some nutritional approaches that can be very cancer-killing
in themselves, improving your health, improving the health of your healthy cells, you're
going to have a better outcome, it just makes sense.
But when you do choose alternative care or to add on alternative care to what you're already
going to do, then that also becomes confusing and we understand that my sisters, friends,
brothers told me to take this or somebody at church, gave me this product, I could take
or I read this on Facebook or I did research on this product, it's very confusing, it's
almost like drinking from a fire hose when you start to do some research on cancer.
We see as our part of your care is to help you wade through that.
We do very specific testing so we can get specific on what diet, what food source is possibly
fueling your cancer, let's eliminate that.
What nutritional product is going to be best for you and your cancer, what's going to be the
best thing to do to help support your cells, what are the best modalities to be used
and with the best frequencies to be used to hold it on your cancer.
Everything is very specific with what we do, ultimately we want the best outcome for you.
So when you combine different things and you're really going to get the best of everything.
So we're not exclusive to standards of care, but we're not always just an add on.
So understand alternative care really should be something everybody should be doing.
And when you do that, when you look at the big picture, when you slow down and you get your
stress levels down, when you utilize somebody like us as a coach for you, that could help relieve
some of the tension that goes along with a cancer diagnosis and ultimately you're going to get the
best results because that's what we want for you. So look at these pages, look at our side,
whether you choose to become a patient of ours, that's okay. Download all my books on this site too.
It'll give you some data so that you can ground yourself and make the best decision possible.
As always, we'll be praying for you.